[Music]
Mr Brown Mr Brown is a clown who rides
through town in
[Music]
Ain found in the we is three CL and top
to is
[Music]
laughing oh what the
confusion ooh yeah yeah
o what about the
[Music]
[Applause]
r who is Mr
Brown I want to know
now he is nowhere to be found
[Music]
and the B just like a b coughing running
around upsetting upsetting upsetting the
down asking for Mr Brown man like
coughing running around up I'm it down
ask I want to
[Music]
know Mr Brown is Mr Brown controlled by
Mo
oh calling
theer and a ghost
ccher this is your chance oh
biger take your chance prove
yourself oh
[Music]
yeah down in parade
W keep running like a